- A lot of you have been asking me
what I've been up to lately,
so here's a quick update,
as well as some behind the
scenes of my latest LA trip.
Boom!
Bow-wop! (laughing)
(upbeat pop music)
- [Radio Announcer] We
have a very special guest.
A very good looking
and a very smart guest, Doctor Mike.
You might know him from Instagram.
He has 2.5 million followers.
- Thank you.
- Why is hot water better and
why is a cold shower better?
- Warm water is better because cold water
shunts blood away from your stomach,
so you don't absorb it as readily.
- You're very knowledgeable,
very visually appealing,
and we really appreciate you being here.
- Thank you so much.
- All right.
(upbeat pop music)
- While I was in LA, I was able to catch
up with some of my old friends.
In fact, my buddy Marco, he
was there at the same time
on a business venture.
We were able to catch up.
He introduced me to his
adorable dog, Titan.
(upbeat pop music)
(smooth hip-hop music)
In 2015, during my little
viral moment of fame,
the first nationally syndicated TV show
that invited me on was The Doctors Show
and they invited me on, obviously,
as "Instagram's sexiest
doctor" as a guest.
(crowd cheers)
And it was a really great
experience, I was able to talk
about how I'm passionate about medicine.
Talk a little bit about
my past and my future.
And, now, to be invited
to the same program
as a host, as a co-host
with these doctors that have
been doing this for 10 years
is such an amazing opportunity.
It really makes me feel
like the whole situation
has come full circle.
Originally, I came on as a guest.
Now, I'm coming out as a co-host.
It shows that I wasn't just popular
for 15 minutes of fame
because of my looks.
I have a medical message that
I wanna get out there to you.
I wanna have fun with
medicine and I think because
you've been so receptive and
shown me so much support,
it's because of that I'm
able to get an opportunity
like co-hosting The Doctors Show.
(smooth hip-hop music)
I was also invited to
the premiere of a movie,
"Flatliners", and it's movie
based on medical students
who were trying to kill
themselves and bring them back
in order to experience the afterlife.
- I would like you to stop my heart.
You give it one minute and
then you bring me back.
(beeps)
- The one thing I'll
say about the movie is
that it totally surprised
me because I thought
it was gonna be maybe a
little science fiction
about medical students and
how medicine can give you
a peek into the afterlife,
when in reality,
it turned out to be a scary movie.
I'm a baby when it comes to
that, so half of the movie,
I was watching like this.
So, if you saw me in the
theater, don't judge me.
Alrighty, so we're headed to
Ricky Dillon's house right now.
We're gonna surprise you with a collab
next week or maybe the
week after, so stay tuned.
The most unique part of my
trip was that I was able to do
something I've never done
before and that's meet this
adorable pig named Luna.
Ricky was able to show
me how smart this pig is.
How if you call the pig,
the pig actually comes over.
I'm totally jealous because
I can't have a pet pig.
New York City has an
explicit ban on pet pigs.
(sad trombone blares)
(smooth hip hop music)
There are new media outlets
out there like Cheddar,
Mashable, Instant, and I do
visit some of those outlets
because I believe that they are doing
a great job for society.
They're taking the
concepts and the formats
of a traditional news network,
but making it a little bit more
millennial friendly and I
could totally get behind that.
Because if I could have
my message reach anybody,
it's millennials, the younger generation.
The biggest impact you
can make on your health
is in your age group, so take listen.
(smooth hip hop music)
The reason you see me meeting
all these television executives
is because I see a fantastic opportunity
right ahead of me.
I'm able to reach and
help millions of people
right in their homes
by being on television
and giving my medical advice.
My goal is not necessarily
to "make it big" on TV.
My goal is to reach the most
amount of people possible
with my medical advice.
As you can tell, I love
traveling and if you travel also,
click this link to see my
travel tips video which give
you all the insider tips
on how I fight jet lag,
how I stay healthy, and
how I pack effectively
when I go on my trips.
It should go without saying,
but all of these amazing
opportunities that I've
been getting recently
really have come because of your support.
Your support for this YouTube channel,
your support for my Instagram.
So, I have to give you a huge thank you.
It really means a great deal to me.
Come here, gimme a hug.
Come here, gimme a hug!
(jazz music)